اشعر وكانه توفي وفه جيده باعتباره مسلم
شهيد ذاهب الى الجنه ولكن في الوقت نفسه
اشعر بالحزن والخساره كان صغير العمر كان
لا يزال امامه
الكثير توفي ابن له الاثنان الاخران لا
يزالان على الخطوط الاماميه في سوريا واما
والدهم ابو بكر فهو بحاجه ماسه الى عودتهم
لوطنهم ويقول انه كاب يعر بالانانيه فهو
يفكر بالاولاد ويدهم خارج
الخطر عامر ولد وترعرع في برايتون بجنوب
بريطانيا كان اول من غادر الى سوريا عندما
كان عمره 19 عاما حمل السلاح قبل سنه مع
جبهه النصره فرع تنظيم القاعده بسوريا
والمدرج على قائمه الجماعات الارهابيه من
شمال غرب سوريا يتحدث معنا عامر عبر سكايب
عن سبب رحيله من بيته الى ساحه
المعركه بالنسبه لي لا يوجد منطق في
الجلوس بينما يتعرض الناس للهجوم لماذا
يعتبر انقاذ شعبك ودينك وواجبك تشددا
لماذا ينظر اليها الناس
كتطلع تناء بنفسك
فحسب في بدايه هذا العام انضم اخواه عبد
الله وجعفر الى الجهاد وكان والدهم قد ذهب
الى سوريا للقيام باعمال الاغاثه ويقول
انه حاول وبدون جدوى اقناع ابنائه
بالتركيز فقط على الجهد الانساني ولكن في
ابريل نيسان سمع ابو بكر الخبر الذي كان
خائفا منه قتل احد ابنائه الثلاثه ويقول
ابو بكر ان عبد الله تقدم الى اراضي الجيش
السوري ثم قام قناص باطلاق النار على صدره
ليسقط على الارض وينظر الى السماء ويضحك
حسب ما وصفه
شقيقه ومنذ اطلاق امريكا غارات جويه على
سوريا علم ابو بكر بالخطر المتزايد على
ابنيه الاخرين تقول امريكا انها تستهدف
داعش وليس جماعه النصره ولكن عامر قال لنا
انه قد تم قصف قاعده النصره بالقرب من
قاعدتهم الاسبوع الماضي ويقول عامر ان
النصره الان قد تعقد صفقه مع داعش لمواجهه
الهجوم الذي قادته
امريكا عمل علماء الاسلام معا من اجل
معاهده السلام بين جميع المجموعات لانهم
يرون ان من الفائده مواجهه التحالف ولكن
لا يزال لدينا خلافات اسلاميه ولكن ابو
بكر يريد نوعا مختلفا من الصفقه يريد عفو
الحكومه البريطانيه والسماح للمجاهدين
الاجانب مثل ابنائه العوده الى وطنهم لا
يبدو وجود نيه لعامر بالعوده ويقول
لعائلته انه ينصحهم بالتحلي بالصبر وكسب
ثواب ذلك وان يتمنوا له الصمود تاركا
لوالده لقطه بصيف قد انتهى بالنسبه
له